bonjour stanislas bozon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous sur
rtl france pour parler de ce phénomène
qui a été révélée dans le journal le
figaro hier les français qui s'arme
murray de plus en plus est-ce que vous
confirmer cette information
alors il est effectivement une
circulation des armes en france qui est
importante
par contre attention à faire le
distinguo entre la partie des chasseurs
ou des tireurs sportifs qui eux
respectent la réglementation de ceux qui
font du trafic d'armes ou utilisent des
armes ou font rentrer des armes sur le
territoire national est ce que nous
constatons surtout c'est que lors de
perquisitions notamment en matière de
stupéfiants nous avons de plus en plus
de saisies d'armes à feu c'est ça qui
inquiète surtout les autorités c'est que
il ya des hommes qui rentre il ya des
hommes qui sortent il ya des hommes qui
sont utilisés notamment sur le terrain
d'autre part je tiens à rappeler aussi
que le service central des armes qui a
évolué et qui maintenant aussi s'occupe
des explosifs parce que nous avons des
importations aussi de d'explosifs
artisanaux et qui nous pose aussi un
problème sur le terrain notamment pour
les policiers alors pour renforcer la
traçabilité des armes le ministère de
l'intérieur a donc présenté hier un
nouvel outil numérique mais vous nous
rappeler que ce qui vous inquiétez
c'était tout l'armement liée à la
délinquance finalement donc cette mesure
de nouvel outil numérique finalement à
quoi ça sert
alors ça sert d'abord avoir une
traçabilité en fait des armes c'est à
dire de savoir où est ce que ce sens
toutes ses armes notamment des chasseurs
des armes de collection les armes qui
parfois c'est un exemple qui était
mentionné notamment dans l'article du
figaro lorsque vous avez une succession
et puis que vous découvrez dans le
grenier de votre grand père ou de votre
père et bien soit des munitions soit une
arme et après vous savez pas trop quoi
en faire donc c'est un système de
traçabilité pour savoir où est-ce
qu'elles sont de faire un état des lieux
exhaustif bien sûr que cet état des
lieux ne va pas faire un état des lieux
de tout ce qui est tout ce qui transite
je dirais de manière complètement
illégal ceci étant ça nous permet quand
même d'avoir la mainmise sur toutes ses
armes et y compris d'ailleurs les
tireurs sportifs et ça nous permet aussi
de corréler parce que vous savez que on
peut notamment
vérifié par rapport à d'autres fichiers
dans le cadre judiciaire notamment les
personnes qui sont interdits de port
d'armes parce que ça c'est un élément
important vous parliez de tireurs
sportifs on se souvient d'ailleurs
quinquin des terroristes il ya quelques
années était lui-même à un tireur
sportif avec des armes qui avaient été
enregistrées donc dont il était en
possession donc le lien parfois peut se
faire entre ce qui est déclaré et ce qui
peut amener à au terrorisme oui alors
les exemples que vous citez en fait
c'est un exemple qui a montré aussi que
le fichier ce qu'on appelle le fichier
agripac qui était l'ancien fichier
l'accompagnent mètres en dessous d'une
nouvelle formule avait effectivement des
failles il n'était pas tout à fait mis à
jour et ça ça c'est une grande
difficulté parce qu'un fichier il a
d'intérêt que si effectivement il est
alimenté il est à jour et qu'il est
utilisé maintenant quand on parle de
de correspondance entre des fichiers
notamment des fichiers judiciaires ça ce
sera le travail aussi et de la
compétence notamment du service central
des armes de bien vérifier que à la fois
ces armes soir ou été neutralisée soit
si elle soit en circulation qu'elles
soient bien enregistré dans le cadre
sportif ou de chasse parce que je
rappelle que en france il n'y a pas de
port d'armes sauf pour des professions
bien spécialisés comme par exemple les
forces de sécurité là actuellement pour
ceux qui font du tir sportif c'est juste
un transport et non pas un port de
larmes qui est autorisé justement on
parle et vous parlez de d'armé illégal
de plus en plus nombreux sur le
territoire français célia quoi selon
vous
d'abord parce que vous savez qu'il ya eu
suite au démantèlement et à la
redistribution notamment de la
cartographie dans beaucoup de pays de
l'est énormément d'armes type
kalachnikov par exemple qui ont inondé
en fait les pays européens c'est un
marché très lucratif puisque vous pouvez
vous procurer des armes pour quelques
centaines d'euros ça c'est possible et
évidemment que à partir du moment où
vous avez une offre et une demande eh
bien vous avez un système parallèle qui
se met en place et c'est bien pour ça
que le service central des armes avaient
été créés en 2010 est que maintenant
avec ce fichier on espère qu'il sera
plus facile d'avoir une traçabilité et
puis surtout de recentrer par exemple
des policiers de terrain sur des
enquêtes judiciaires pour démonter par
exemple des réseaux de trafic d'armes
ils sont souvent d'ailleurs en lien avec
le trafic de stupéfiants vous parliez
également de la question des explosifs
là encore un problème inquiétant
oui un problème inquiétant parce que
depuis plusieurs mois nous constatons
sur le terrain que des mortiers
d'artifices par exemple ou des explosifs
artisanaux sont utilisées à l'encontre
des forces de sécurité et ceci inquiète
évidemment parce que je rappelle que des
policiers sur le terrain pas c'est eux
qui en subissent évidemment les
conséquences qui sont attaqués très
régulièrement il se passe pas une
journée sans qu'il y ait des tirs de
mortiers d'artifice alors il ya une
législation sion qui s'est mis en place
depuis quelques semaines et qui a été un
peu dur si évidemment par les
parlementaires et par le ministère de
l'intérieur maintenant sur le terrain
encore faut-il avoir assez de moyens et
d'effectifs pour mener à bien des
enquêtes parce que souvent on ne
reproche un taux d'élucidation par
rapport aux enquêtes mais encore faut-il
bien sûr simplifier la procédure pénale
pour faciliter le travail des enquêteurs
donné d accès plus facile notamment à
tous les fichiers par exemple j'ai lu
dans l'article certains s'interrogeaient
sur la possibilité pour les services de
renseignements de consulter par exemple
des fichiers mais il faut savoir que les
services de renseignement c'est leur
coeur de métier justement d'avoir accès
à ses fichiers de croiser et de faire
notamment du renseignement pour pouvoir
porter à la connaissance notamment des
autorités administratives et judiciaires
d'éléments qui serait en illégalité
totale avec la loi merci beaucoup c'est
miss l'asg aux dons pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué général syndicat alliance police